c'est un documentaire de romain verley
un journaliste qui a travaillé avec
patrick poivre d'arvor il ya une dizaine
d'années juste qu'il soit licencié et
qui a travaillé sur lui pendant de
nombreux mois et qui nous révèle de
grosses grosses chaude et notamment d un
témoignage nouveaux qui arrivent et qui
parle d'un viol qui parle d'une
tentative de viol on a aussi le
témoignage de frédérique lantieri connu
pour faites entrer l'accusé qui explique
qu'elle a été harcelé humiliée après
avoir refusé ses avances on a aussi une
stagiaire de l'époque qui a été harcelé
longuement fin c'est ce qui est révélé
dans le dans le complément dans
complément d'enquêté pardon et ce qui
est hyper intéressant c'est que le
journaliste complément d'enquêté
explique que il pensait on est en
travail a été fait en ayant travaillé
avec patrick poivre d'arvor que les
portes s'ouvriraient plus facilement
pour lui en fait pas du tout en fait a
été très très très compliqué ils
dénoncent ils donnent quelques
interviews depuis quelques jours une
omerta réel
concernant le système patrick poivre
d'arvor qui est révélée en fait dans ce
documentaire il ya le parquet de
nanterre qui a donc confirmé une plainte
la plainte que j'évoquais à l'instant
viol tentative de viol d'une femme qui
est prénommé angélique c'est un prénom
d'emprunt et patrick poivre d'arvor ce
qui est extrêmement nouveau aussi est
très très fort c'est qu'ils portent
plainte contre les 16 contre 16 femmes
qui l'accusent 16 sur 20 mais c'est sur
l'un d'eux est non seulement ils portent
plainte mais il produit des documents
recevoir des lettres qu'il aurait reçu
de certaines d'entre elles
qui légitimerait les relations sexuelles
qu'il avait que ces personnes et qui
aujourd'hui le dénonce il ya quelque
chose de très fort aussi en fait il a
produit un document de 43 pages auprès
des forces de l'ordre et des autorités
dans lequel il dénonce le système mis
tout il le dit très clairement il
dénonce la liberté de parole des femmes
depuis ce qui me ce qui interpelle un
peu c est ce que complément d'enquêté
doivent quand même de faire de faire une
émission comme ça sinon pas l'épreuve et
si on veut avoir porté plainte et ce
qu'on sait c'est normal ça en cours ce
n'est pas incompatible oui la sphère est
en cours mais eux ont des témoignages
lui apporter plein de sa plainte avait
été retoquée et lahi la plainte avec
constitution de partie civile donc il a
tout à fait le droit et chacun le droit
de travailler comme ça cc il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité jury mais morale à mon
avis parce que ces femmes se sont montés
en collectif c'est un collectif qui est
le collectif mis tout média est en fait
l'avocate d'avocate de quelques unes de
ces de ces femmes dit en gros là là le
fait que poivre d'arvor porte plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse
cal calomnieuse c'est une une façon
d'une vigne à une sorte d'intimidation
pour que les d'éventuelles nouvelles
victimes maintenant on va demander à
quelqu'un qui a des infos gilles de la
dette alors non ce qui m'étonnait c'est
que toutes ces femmes est attendu
longtemps mais surtout ce monde dans un
collectif porte plainte ensemble mène
une action commune tout ensemble et en
fait j'ai enquêter là dessus et j'ai
découvert que c'était absolument pas un
hasard si elles se mettent ensemble
parce que j'ai retrouvé des faits qui
m'ont halluciné qui montre que de mon
point de vue et d'après les éléments que
j'ai des affaires ont été étouffées et
je vous le dis elles ont été étouffés
très probablement par un système que
vous évoquez mais aussi un système
médiatique et j'espère que non mais
peut-être aussi un système judiciaire
alors il ya huit fait huit fait que j'ai
retrouvé il ya quatre faits de
harcèlement sexuel il ya deux agressions
sexuelles et il ya deux viols et c8 fait
il ya eu des plaintes il ya eu une
enquête et ses huit faits sont arrivés à
un procureur ces huit faits ont été
considérés à un moment par la justice
comme commis alors je prends toutes les
précautions d'usagé il est non seulement
présumé innocent mais il est même pas
mis en examen bon présumé innocent
d'accord mais néanmoins moi j'ai
retrouvé trace de faits commis ce qui
veut dire que donc il ya des femmes qui
ont porté plainte à l'époque et un viol
par exemple en 2009 qui est avérée il ya
des femmes qui ont porté plainte des
affaires qui ont été au bout il n'y a
pas eu de suite en justice c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui elles se réunissent et
qu'elle se dit ça ne peut plus durer
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui qui à la fin
de cette omerta voilà florian d'autres
infos ou et dans ce faux faut préciser
qu'à quand même 26 femmes qui ont qui
sont allés voir les autorités dans une
session qui ont porté plainte et elles
sont toutes évidemment d'accord terrifié
horrifié par les par la plainte de
patrick poivre d'arvor et ya hélène de
vaincre de ving qui me suis mal exprimé
sur l'émetteur et elle n'est pas la
seule d'ailleurs qui l a réagi elle est
horrifié par le fait qu' ils veulent il
veut en plus les
leur faire porter le chapeau à les faire
passer pour des bordés harceleuse pour
des menteuses ce qu'elles ne sont on
imagine tous a priori pas et ce qui est
assez extraordinaire on se souvient de
la une de paris match et quelques temps
qu'ils le montent qui montent rien on en
avait parlé dans tpm people comme un
paria très peu d'émissions il vivait
seul dans son coin et en même temps ce
qui était souligné dans l'article et
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui parce
que moi j'ai quelques échos et quelques
infos en ce sens là il continue de
sortir beaucoup il voit beaucoup de gens
et tient toujours le même discours idrac
toujours autant il s'amuse histoire
comme si il tient toujours même discours
en disant qu'il est victime d'une cabale
est ce qu'il dit autour de lui c'est ce
qu'il dit en permanence et c'est ce qui
est reflété dans les 43 pages qu'il a
portée aux autorités dans lequel il
dénonce en gros le mouvement mis tout
pour résumer je reprends un fait c'est
une agression sexuelle dont je n'avais
jamais entendu parler qui a été d'après
les éléments d'enquêté que j'ai on va
mettre qui auraient été commises dans un
ministère le ministère de la culture je
n'en ai jamais entendu parler pour le
moment cette agression elle est pour moi
daté de 2009 il ya eu une enquête il ya
une procédure je n'ai pas vu de jugement
je n'ai pas vu de suite donc encore une
fois présomption d'innocence mais ces
femmes aujourd'hui elle dit ça ne peut
plus durer